trois ans qu'ils attendaient de remonter
en division honneur leur ticket a
officiellement été validée ce dimanche
19 mars
les joueurs du sky rugby ont réussi
cette performance grâce à leur 13e
victoire de la saison en 15 matches
disputés leurs victimes du jour
champagne saint-andré verger et saint
quentinois n'ont pas fait de détails en
leur infligeant une véritable correction
36 à 5 avec six essais inscrits on a su
dominer on a su mettre la main sur le
ballon marquer des essais quand il
fallait marquer les essais quand il
fallait garder la balle plus de fois on
leur a laissé un peu le ballon ils nous
ont quand même mis en danger ça s'est vu
ce n'était pas ce n'est pas une équipe
une équipe avec la victoire assurée non
plus avec dix points d'avancé sur le 2e
chilly mazarin le sky rugby ne peut plus
être rejoint et obtient l'une des
montées les plus rapides de cette saison
en ile-de-france sexe et tôt dans
l'année
ça nous permet de nous préparer au mieux
pour les prochaines encore malgré tout
on voit que m'assieds montée en pro d2
la semaine dernière nous cette semaine
donc voilà c'est très bien comme ça plus
eto'o on a le temps de on se fait pas
peur au moins cette année donc c'est
parfait ça se prépare
dans les têtes déjà parce qu'on monte de
division c'est une vision qu'ils ont
connue avec des difficultés par moments
donc ça se prépare dans la terre ça se
prépare aussi dans le jeu ça se prépare
à plein de niveaux même au niveau du
club il ya plein de choses à mettre en
place donc c'est beaucoup de travail
mais ça donne ça donne vraiment envie
d'aller travailler
les dirigeants ont déjà fixé les
objectifs pour la saison prochaine le
maintien en honneur
en attendant les joueurs du sky rugby
peuvent savourer leur exploit